the most important question is what are
you trying to do like are you trying to
make more money are you trying to build
a huge company are you looking for
legacy but if you're better people
you'll probably make more profit in 2020
and have more time for yourself like
when you put yourself out there you deal
with the ramifications of the end
consumer or the b2b consumer judgement
everybody gets hyped when I hide them
like this then they do it for four days
a week a month
nothing happens they're like [ __ ] that
it depends on what your ambition is
right so like you know that's the most
important question like for me the
number one ambition for me coming out of
school was to repay my parents that's
what built the business for my parents
for 12 years then I went on to money
like so
like they're just the most important
question is what are you trying to do
like are you trying to make more money
are you trying to build a huge company
are you looking for legacy do you want
to move to Seattle so does that come in
the form of like you just want your
business to grow Facebook and Instagram
video content about you being a real
estate agent people struggle all of you
struggle producing content because you
think you have desks have something to
say and my point is if you just tell me
what happened that's more than enough on
the Delta of not doing anything at all
what I need to get people to understand
is most people say well my life is
boring and I have nothing to say and
they just don't put out content and I'm
just like if you first video of every
day was about the Nationals or the
Capitals or the Wizards you will get
business because I promise you if you
made [ __ ] Jets content and I saw it
I'd buy my house from you I make
decisions
it's better than not but but it's a but
but I love that you said I love how
quickly you responded it's a very
important moment just so you know 99.99%
of everybody who's ever heard anything
from me decided not is better than the
Wizards thing so the answer is more
volume but the part that everyone's
struggling with is nobody's it's all
insecurities nobody's listening I got
two likes it doesn't look good is this
is anybody listening to this everybody
quits everybody gets hyped when I hate
them like this then they do it for four
days a week a month
nothing happens they're like [ __ ] that
did you look carefully at the 2009 and
2010 tweets how much engagement they had
yeah
did you or not you know that some of
those tweets only had two likes and a
share people forget what my two thousand
nine and ten looked like everybody
starts with only one like here's the
tactical part you put a ton of content
eventually something kind of goes viral
and you spend a fuckload of money
against it because people prove that
they gave a [ __ ] this is actually a
stunningly easy answer and outrageously
difficult for small businesses to
execute number one pay $18 an hour let's
start let's go block by block if I if
you know if I bought your business into
your business and now we were partners
and we started tomorrow and you're like
all right here we are 9:00 a.m. Monday
right you'd say this is our biggest
problem I'd say okay who are our
competitors and or similar businesses to
us even if they didn't do the same exact
thing doctors offices versus
dermatologists dentists whatever right
and how do we figure out and I'm being
dead serious right now how do we figure
out like I used to go to liquor stores
as a customer and if I thought somebody
had any level of hustle or charisma I
took no I didn't try I always it's funny
I would go to see it I never would poach
somebody in it cuz that for some reason
was my line of disrespectful but then I
would always come back to my store and
ask my salespeople who were part of the
industry to get me that person's number
or do you know this person you could
call
read Yelp reviews you could figure out
who they are and literally just pay them
more when I hear I want to grow create
abundance for my family but not always
be there that means you have to hire
people like like if you don't want to be
there and you want to be home or you
want to at least be able to mentally
relax on a Friday afternoon well then
you need to pay 18 not 14 people create
these arbitrary numbers well salespeople
in the Sugarland area they get this
commit like why do you know why people
are charging 30 percent for like
back-end kind of infrastructure on
technology because Apple decided 30
percent was the rake they were gonna
take for the app store and that became
the standard and had they decided 27
bless you read or 33 or something else
that's what everybody would do my senior
executive team was like but this is
what's going on in and I'm like that's
nothing to with Vayner there's places
where we have to overpay and there's
places we should not pay anything
because we're bait like you have to play
in the reality so the first thing that
comes to mind is you'll get better
people if you pay 18 and if you run the
math and you can afford that there's
something funny that happens you may
make a little less profit in the next
six months but if you have better people
you'll probably make more profit in 2020
and have more time for yourself number
two then you get into retention and
retention is really completely
predicated on communication you have to
be willing to my dad would never talk to
his employees cuz he didn't want them to
ask him for a raise it's real like and
so that worked for nobody
he might have extracted a little less
cost for six or nine months but then he
had a deal with the ramifications of
people leaving right
I think it's communication
if you're trying to reach me to be
people you run ads on LinkedIn for
employees of those b2b organizations so
they pass on that content and that
content is strictly for b2b on b2c when
you run Instagram story ads would swipe
up to your landing page you run them
what's crazy is it's funny this is back
to and versus or because you come from a
TV back this is like back to like me
literally on a plane being like wait a
minute I'll hire somebody then I'll feel
bad if I let him down like strategy's
crazy you're literally one thought away
from changing everything and you can't
even see what's in front of you
it's you're asking an or question when
the answer is an aunt it's a both TV was
tough you had to pick one commercial
this is why you guys over thought the
[ __ ] out of it that's why he tested the
[ __ ] out of it because once you had it
whatever [ __ ] you were doing it was
running on remnant late night and you
were at the mercy of how good it was
so I proactive got so big because they
had call centers and they really ran
data and they were doing a bunch of
different commercials and they're like
that but you didn't do that right you
like did your shoot you [ __ ] did your
best and you [ __ ] it right that's right
but that's but I'm social you just run
58 pieces of content cuz you doesn't
cost you a lot to make the content and
you just see what actually converts
Facebook is not your foundational page
it's the content you know like I don't
care if you have a single thought like
if somebody said Gary but I'm
embarrassed I have a Madigan's I I don't
have a single follower on Instagram I'm
like cool just run ads your Facebook
page is not your foundational page you
know it was foundational for people
maybe six seven years ago when the
organic reach was so bonkers but that
went away so even if you have two
million followers on Facebook it's not
if I'm getting a 20th of the organic
reach I got two years ago from Facebook
even though I have 15% more followers on
it because they killed organic reach to
put more ads into the funnel got it so
face so basically every they used to
call them dark posts right basically
you're just running ads on Facebook and
Instagram but you're driving them to
your
mobile-optimized landing page right
don't forget you're in a mobile world
now a lot of people if they've been
around for a little bit they've
maximized the desktop but when you land
on a mobile device which is where
Facebook and Instagram is gonna be
consumed got it the vulnerabilities you
create on the judgement of the people
you're trying to sell to right Pfizer
awarded vaynermedia a three million
dollar piece of business four years ago
but then a board member saw me cursing
in a YouTube video and killed the deal
you said that you were a Patriots fan
and I no longer wanted to be your friend
like when you put yourself out there you
deal with the ramifications of the end
consumer or the b2b consumer judgment
some struggle with the judgement of just
the human aspect but on the business
side you will win and will lose business
because there are plenty Pete like I
like your energy but I know your energy
there's a lot of people that wouldn't
like it you know your life the end and
and and I think what will work for you
based on my quick read is you probably
realize it's a net-net game right if you
have 17 people that love it and 13
people that hate it you're a plus 4
versus a zero yeah look you're talking
to somebody who first 20 years of his
career I couldn't sell wine on the
internet to the state of Texas you sleep
in the bed that you choose the end like
you're in that industry the good news is
nobody else can do it - right
so you have to lay in that bed like we
work with chase we work with Diageo I
have a cannabis agency like they don't
take Facebook and Instagram ads that's
what I do right so you just live in the
reality what I would say though is
knowing a lot of these rules and
regulations because of the clients I
have there's a lot of lawyers that are
lazy as [ __ ] and would rather just say
to you something basic without actually
pushing it could you put those things in
your profile and then not have to put it
on every piece of content it depends on
the interpretation of the lawyer got it
so like what
I get upset for people in regulated
industries is they have lazy legal
advice that is so conservative because
they just don't even want to deal with
[ __ ] right because that's how you
maximize your money if you're a lawyer
and so it's your job to push you know
you have to take the temperature your
company I remember when Smith & Wesson
the gun company came to us I decided to
pass on it because I just didn't feel
the culture at Vayner would accept us
taking a gun climate client during nine
months after school shooting in
Connecticut you know even the money was
huge you know Steve Ross CEO Nerdist
stadium in the Dolphins when I decide I
want to take cannabis company clients I
knew that the NFL in cannabis just was
gonna take some time and so I had to
make an investment another company yeah
I mean uh then there's other times where
the liberal nation of nature of my
company goes the other way I remember
when we wanted to work with a gas
company we assigned somebody who I love
very much I'd actually like them to come
back into our world doesn't work at
Vayner right now he came to me and said
I'm not gonna work on this brand and I
don't think a lot of people are gonna
work on it and I punched him in his
[ __ ] face verbally you know because I
was like well then why then let's not
work with Pepsi cause sugar is bad too
and as a matter of fact let's not work
with Calvin Klein because textiles are
the second worst contributor to the
invite I'm like [ __ ] you with your
liberal [ __ ] like like I'm really
I'm outrageously socially liberal I was
passed on Smith & Wesson I passed on
other things but then there becomes a
line where you're just getting into
foo-foo [ __ ] New York LA Europe [ __ ]
and that's when I get pissed and so like
and by the way that's what my job as the
CEO is so every company this is the best
part about it being CEO everything right
and everything wrong is unbelievably
tied to her or him right and so I make
those judgment calls all the time
if you put out a daily show about the
trials and tribulations at your
dealership and you put it on Facebook
and YouTube your business would explode
now nobody's gonna give a [ __ ] for a
year so for a year
you're gonna put some real money in but
it's a hell of a lot better than the
[ __ ] advertising you're doing now in
the paper and billboards and radio if
you're doing that and amortize it over
time but it will work because you've got
one you know you know right now that you
have one employee that's a real
character and that becomes your [ __ ]
you know Fonz I really want somebody to
do that because it's really gonna work
and what you can do let me tell you how
I would direct it or produce it so now
you got Caleb he's just filming all day
funny things are happening [ __ ] you
Charlie like you guys speak whatever you
make but what Caleb does better than
d-roc or better than anybody who's ever
filmed me is he will ask me questions
while we're filming he just did it on
the back of the cab now about how I post
on Instagram and I think you should do
that I think you should film the show
and then stop and go to the parts and
service team and start a segment in each
episode called how not to come here
let me explain if you have a segment
that's 2 minutes long in every episode
so think about it it's almost like it's
a show but then it stops and there's
like now an information piece in the
middle of it where the people that do
parts of service for you tell the
viewers at home how not to come to the
Auto Body Shop because the amount of
people that come to parts and services
when they could have done something very
simple at home but they're like me and
have no fun when I tell you I have no
[ __ ] idea I'd rather throw my car in
the garbage then figure out how to fix
it like and I'm talking about 2 minutes
if you're like change the spark plug I'm
like I'm gonna leave it on the road and
go buy another car like literally
there's a lot of people like that if you
had a segment the amount of trust that
your organization would get so what I
did with mine Library TV I literally
told people to not buy wine we sold and
I did it like emphatically
I'm like this [ __ ] sucks right if you
did that it would change your business
and then you'd be able to chop out that
little piece and do it as a separate
one-minute video on Instagram you see
where I'm going and that's what Linds
we'll go into a little bit but that's
how I would produce it and then you can
strip the audio and have a podcast for
no cost
[Music]